[Music]
welcome to the Jeselnik and Rosenthal
vanity project junior junior vice
president two and a half years later
true love rises again you think you
watched football last weekend then
you're damn fool you watch nothing the
season starts now right where we're
taping this in Hollywood
Bernstein hi the Los Angeles Times
reporting the allegations that two
students at the high school spiked their
high school teams water at a junior
varsity football practice with a male
enhancement drug has prompted an
investigation that led to the dismissal
of varsity coach Luis Barajas now Greg
when they say male enhancement like I
know you've got you've got you know a
little bit of everything back at your
home you know which one it was and what
are the effects they didn't specify I
mean I would assume it was a Viagra or
Cialis like product they did not even
find evidence that the students actually
drank the contaminated water they spoke
to some doctors who said they would
really need to know how much you drank
of this male enhancement product didn't
know what the effects could be on a high
school student but I think we can all
imagine here's what I'll say okay and
this should be common sense first of all
this was a junior varsity team and in
the JV anything goes secondly how do you
know if a bunch of 13 and 14 year olds
have taken viagra that's like a placebo
for a 14 year old boy we're talking
Flintstone vitamin level uselessness to
a fourteen-year-old boy
and they put it in the water during
practice listen if you love the game the
way my father loved the game and my
grandfather loved the game then you
practice with a full erection or you sit
the sidelines flaccid because you must
be injured if you're not running sprints
and full pads with all the blood and
your penis goddamn PC culture is ruining
the game I don't even get to follow up
on the fact that your dad and grand
father used to just play football with
the full-on erection they played against
each other so we heard all the stories I
don't know how it worked out but yeah
full-blown it's like if you weren't
if you would like they started to wear
cups just so you wouldn't be able to
find out if they had the erection not so
that you could like I'm okay to go in
the game coach kind of thing like what
we're what we're Thanksgivings like in
the back backyard of the Jeselnik castle
I mean it was fun
we didn't play football we just kind of
just sat around and kind of like threw
the football around with erections
[Music]
you